[Applause]
Patrick eNOS and we're thrilled to have
you with us here today in Durham 52
degrees our gametime temperature as the
Bulls get ready for Game two of this
four-game series against the Charlotte
Knights excellent deep right toward the
wall goes right us in the chat and the
boos have a one nothing lead
[Music]
baseball is a game of failure guys who
hit 300 failed 70% of the time and go to
the Hall of Fame so they are considered
a heroes and the best so ever played in
the game I think a lot of people who
have a lot of debt have a really
difficult time a high fail rate trying
to get through debt because it's a
long-term commitment so here to do a
debt-free screen I am I love it I love
it how much have you paid off I paid off
one hundred and seventy six thousand
dollars in six and a half years Wow is
it your house it is consumer debt and
laughs way to code I've never been as
confident in myself as a person that I
have been since I made that last payment
doc on mortgage it just gives me a whole
different outlook I'm not chasing life
anymore and kind of leading my own life
part of my responsibility here today to
thank the others because the other
debt-free screamer all the other debt
priests because I've been in my car
screaming with them that's right with
them high-fiving them and that's what's
helped to keep me motivated so that's
one of the reasons I'm here because when
you're looking at a board that says you
owe 150 $1,000 Wow and you only make 50
the math just doesn't work on how you're
gonna get there but created a couple of
new businesses started a website we
started a camp for kids who want to
follow in all of our footsteps on the
sports broadcasting side it's not all
about generating revenue but it's about
generating I don't know good revenue a
feel good revenue because I don't just
want to make money with what I sell for
the goals I want my partner's my clients
to feel like they're being treated
really well and they're not getting
taken the cleaners so that type of feel
good work it takes a special person to
win and especially in baseball baseball
is the ultimate team sport but on the
other hand it's the ultimate individual
sport and that's that's what it comes
down to with your finances for Patrick
it was like a huge weight just was
lifted
you have your team goals but you have
your individual goals and you know the
ones that make it to the top the ones
that make it to the big leagues and
you know have successful big league
careers those are the ones putting in
the effort the attention to detail and
that's what it takes for finances katha
my fiancee she's just the best just the
absolute best when did I first bring up
Dave Ramsey and Dave Ramsey will even
laugh at this first date first date and
I remember I told her that one of my
goals in the next year and a half was to
pay off my home
Patrick Raleigh North Carolina one
hundred and seventy six thousand dollars
paid off in six and a half years making
forty three up to 105 count it down
brother
bottom of the ninth inning financial
Series Game seven three one in favor of
crushing debt leading financial freedom
bases loaded two outs on the mound is
chase the indomitable closer he's a
Mariano Rivera of debts but the bases
are loaded for financial freedom honda
freedom at third he liked freedom at
second mortgage freedom at first penis
steps into the box here's the pitch a
swing and a line drive down the
left-field line this is fair coming in
is honda freedom to score he like
freedom rounding third base he's gonna
score to tie the game here comes the
game-winning run around for third base
the throw home from Ocwen mortgage it's
on the play that may get him the slide
the tag he's safe he's safe he's dead
free
[Music]